cuando tenía 8 años de colegio
de hecho quería aprender las nuestras
porque en el idioma de moda
y también aprendí
me inscribí en un colegio de aprender
inglés insigne toda mi escolaridad y
gracias a esto salí hablando
y la verdad que trajo muchísimos
beneficios entre ellos creo que el
principal sería comunicarme con otras
personas de diferentes partes del
planeta
de hecho es toro
no pude experimentar gracias incluso
cuando viaje a europa
de hecho que quede más bien en
inglaterra pero la realidad es que como
la de indonesia estaba ahí haciendo
exactamente lo mismo que yo
y gracias a eso nos podríamos comunicar
no solamente puede conseguir conocerla y
conocer sobre su cultura sino que ella
sobre una mía sino que además el día de
hoy mantenemos contacto más gracias a
las redes sociales y así he logrado que
hablar muchas otras personas de otras
partes del mundo de centroamérica de
asia de europa ya sea cara cara o
virtual y bueno la verdad que no lo
hubiera podido hacer si no hubiera
aprendido otro idioma
pero hoy me quiero enfocar en los
beneficios cognitivos que tiene aprender
un idioma y habla de cualquier idioma no
solamente inglés puede ser inglés ahora
a mí
las estudios de idiomas no sólo nos
permite comunicarnos a otras personas
sino aunque traen cambios en el cerebro
uno de ellos no se sigan en aquí que
tiene un familiar o un conocido que haya
padecido o que padezca una enfermedad
neurodegenerativa como el alzheimer
o alguna relacional
bueno en el cuento que aprendan un
idioma puede ayudar a prevenir dura
y también a reducir ya bajar el signo de
avance de esta enfermedad
por qué pasa esto porque tenemos una
característica en nuestro cerebro es
llamar neuroplasticidad que es la
capacidad del cerebro humano para
regenerarse y cambiar su estructura
aprendiendo un idioma lo que logramos es
que a través de las actividades que se
realizan durante el proceso de
aprendizaje por ejemplo lo hace de dar
opiniones debatir dar de analizar
patrones entre muchas otras
das los míos y argumentar la la red es
lo que nos permite poder crear estas
conexiones entre neuronas y que el
cerebro vacío se genera no se vaya a
cambiar nuestra estructura y de esta
forma favorezca haga que digamos que ser
euros básicamente funcione mejor y de
forma más difícil
de hecho hace un tiempo atrás haciendo
investigación para esta charla
me enteré de que hay varios médicos
receta o quedan como remedio como
paliativo el aprendizaje del idioma
cualquiera sea para pacientes que vienen
ya de granada
y esto es porque esto permite que una
enfermedad amase más lento y que también
el cambio se no sea que tengan una mejor
calidad de vida básicamente porque lo
mantiene su cerebro y su mente activa
gracias a que van y estudian y critican
y debaten ideas opiniones y las
argumentan y analizan información a
través de las diferentes actividades
de bueno de despertar este será que esto
será que estas personas tienen que
estudiar antes
o pueden hacerlo además gran delincuente
mayor pero la verdad es que sí bien
carla neuroplasticidad su capacidad de
influir depende de cada persona y
depende del edad recientes que ninguna
edad se queda totalmente afuera
de hecho con este pelo a todos los que
son adultos
o incluso en personas mayores de 70 años
las invito a que aprendan un idioma el
que quieran en que deseen pero que
aprendan un idioma y puedan gozar de
mantener su mente activa y seguir
teniendo estas ventajas que nos puede
traer nuestro propio cerebro hace unos
años atrás esté enseñando a adultos me
encontré con un par de personas mayores
de 70 años que quería inglés
me encontré con suerte porque quería no
hacerlo porque si bien viajaban quizás
no lo hacían dando las dos me dijeron
que eran porque querían mantener su
mente activa porque saben que estudian
nuevas cosas y particularmente aprender
un idioma nos iba a ayudar así que nunca
es tarde nunca es tarde para poder gozar
no dijo del todo pero por lo menos de
algunos de los beneficios de aprender
y sin más desde otro cerebro no es
suficientemente importante ya que tengo
mucho más
pero vas tan desordenada
te quiero también consultar si aquellas
personas que han estudiado
han estudiado este idioma en la niñez
y seguro que en esta audiencia de haber
varios en cualquiera de estas tres
etapas de recuento que para estas
personas también hay otros beneficios
una practicidad
y estos son beneficios en el pensamiento
en el desarrollo del pensamiento crítico
y el desarrollo del pensamiento lógico
no se les abran está dando el
pensamiento crítico como es lógico se
encuentran en pleno desarrollo
de la etapa de la niñez y la
adolescencia
y la verdad es que aprender el idioma
también con basura y esto no solamente
porque en una clase de idioma pueden
debatir o porque pueden dar su opinión
como que pueden contar sobre ellos
mismos y contar que les guste y porque
si es porque aparte pueden hacer
actividades como la de analizar los
patrones de regularidad dentro del
idioma es decir hay una estructura
gramatical o seis piezas de vocabulario
que sigan algún patrón y esto nos ayuda
a desarrollar el pensamiento crítico y
sobre todo el pensamiento lógico
y estoy seguro que más de uno de los que
han estudiado llegamos acá cuando lo
hizo y lo comparó con el español y de
hdd con esto gracias esa comparación
también pues en ejercitar el pensamiento
lógico y el crítico empezar porque son
digamos diferentes y por qué es que
están en culturas diferentes donde
mostró vídeos
[Música]
y son estructuras también entonces nos
permite analizar y hacer correr
estamos cambio y de paso ayudar al
cerebro a que desarrolle su función
cognitiva
bien además de todo esto y seguramente
cuando aprendieron idiomas aprenderán
sobre otros temas
por ejemplo hace un tiempo tenía que
prepararme para un examen de
internacional y bueno en ejercicio rizar
prácticas para el examen sobre todo en
mucho electo comprensión entre otras
habilidades y mientras practicaba
parálisis para este examen me encontré
con un texto de genes en inglés que
hablaban sobre el uso de espejos
ahora tenían que leer analizarlo
entenderlo y yo les puede decir que en
vida tanto como estudiantes como con
prost al inglés me iba a imaginar que
iba a terminar leyendo un texto sobre el
uso de espejos técnicos de la amplia
psicoterapia puede ser pero la verdad
nuestro experto aseguró que no
ustedes lo leyó y aprendo sobre este
tema obviamente depende mucho pero algo
aprendí y como este conocimiento aquí
hay muchos otros conocimientos en
historia en otras de otras culturas de
geografía y de muchas otras mareas que
temáticas que toda la gente le gustaría
imaginarse
sí y esto la verdad es un beneficio de
aprender idiomas porque un idioma como
el ig es una cultura
y la cultura no es solamente la cosa que
la vida de la gente común hace en su
historia es su geografía es la actividad
viene especialistas en la forma de
pensar es todo todo esto puede ser
cultural y propio y puede ser aprendido
a través del idioma y la verdad este es
un gran beneficio porque porque hoy en
día y sobre todo desde nuevo de la
pandemia y con la globalización nos
estamos dando cuenta de que es cada vez
más necesario ser ciudadanos globales y
tener un conocimiento general y el mundo
para poder entender a las otras personas
comunicarnos más fácilmente y establecer
relaciones con personas de otras partes
[Música]
sinceramente si no aprendiendo un idioma
es una gran manera
sólo un vivir imaginado nunca aprender
vamos sobre los espejos o aprender sobre
historia norteamericana o solideo
literatura inglesa o sobre historia de
asia
porque lo aprendí de hecho pero la
verdad estamos en medio idiomas
y bueno de esto aparte de que no agregue
conocimiento y no hace más corto y más
globalizados y entre también un lado un
impacto en nuestro cerebro y es que hay
mayor conexión de neuronas
nosotros podemos relacionar los tenemos
más fácilmente y conectar las neuronas
más fácilmente y esto permite de vuelta
que el cerebro se maneje mejor
además facilita entre la conexión entre
los dos hemisferios si bien cada uno
tiene un hemisferio que es predominante
sobre el otro aquellas personas que son
turba de papel aprende de un idioma que
puede permitir ser más creativos y
aquellos que sean diestros les puede
permitir ser más gráficos
y con fortalecer esta conexión el grupo
hemisferios
ya abre y terminando quiero invitarlos
ya que cada persona es diferente y cada
proceso de aprendizaje también lo eres
quiero invitarlos a que piensen en
cuáles sean que han estudiado o han
estudiado cuáles son los beneficios que
ustedes obtuvieron a partir del
aprendizaje de un vídeo
que mienten y que piensan cuáles podrían
obtener o cuáles podrían necesitar lejos
y cuáles de podemos permitir cambiar sus
vidas muchas gracias